la chose la plus importante là c'est la
guerre en Ukraine faut pas l'oublier que
c'est la guerre en Ukraine et que et que
c'est très grave ce qui se passe j'ai
l'impression quelquefois d'être
peut-être en 1933 quoi et d'entendre des
gens en France des hommes politiques
dire des choses terribles et et me dire
on est en 33 et qu'est-ce que ces gens
auraient fait en 42 donc tous les partis
extrémistes français et tout disent des
choses terribles et si cet hiver on doit
baisser le chauffage de de 1 degré et
ben c'est pas très grave il faut pas
oublier tout ce que nos parents nos
grands-parents ont vécu à partir de 1940
ah quand les acteurs comme ça ici d'être
intelligent toujours compliqué non mais
c'est vrai est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qu'il dit ou pas parce que c'est
fait défoncer
je sais pas pour voilà bon après c'est
vrai que Jean-Paul Rouve après voilà oui
je comprends le tollé d'abord c'est non
visiblement il ne comprend rien à rien
il ne sait pas là c'est ça en fait c'est
la désinvolture il parle de l'histoire
rien du tout d'ailleurs il le dit
lui-même je suis pas faire une actualité
puis il se lance donc il est riche
mais en fait on comprend pas ce qu'il
dit c'est ridicule et n'importe quoi
avec des inventures il dit Besson
chauffage mais pour des gens qui vont
pas bien leur facture c'est le chauffage
ça va être un drame des enfants vont
avoir froid et lui dire
voilà il pense pour lui en fait
il se rend pas compte que pas des gens
comment ils font comment ils font son
chauffage l'autre il il il est énorme
il dort seul Jean-Paul qui commence à
faire les tuches qui nous fasse pas
chier oui non mais au-delà du fond de ce
qu'il dit sur la forme abrutement sur la
forme quand on voit ces images on peut
pas s'empêcher de voir un espèce de bobo
qui méprise profondément le peuple qui
se moque du peuple d'ailleurs dans ses
propres films
il a oublié il a oublié de faire des
sacrifices je pense qu'à un moment donné
il faut se mettre à la place des gens
tout le monde n'a pas la chance d'être
sans doute millionnaire pour gagner très
bien sa vie comme lui de vivre peut-être
dans des très beaux appartements des
très belles maisons oui pour plein de
gens c'est un gros sacrifice de baisser
le chauffage et c'est vrai que sacrifice
concret du quotidien et franchement il
faut mieux de se mettre à la place des
gens mais moi je l'aime bien notre Jeff
Tuche
maman
qu'est-ce que tu veux mon chéri non ce
que je veux dire moi c'est que sur le
fond fond qui puisse dire que la guerre
en Ukraine c'est un peu plus important
que de baisser son chauffage on peut
l'entendre mais comme il le dit très mal
savent que nous ce qu'on nous ce qu'on
retient c'est ça va baisser le chauffage
cet hiver c'est pas très grave les gars
bah c'est pour lui exactement pour lui
mais pour lui il vient n'importe quoi
très maladroit et on ne sait même pas ce
qu'il dit d'accord que voilà ça sera pas
un problème chez les riches tu as des
cheminées des belles bagnoles on sait
très bien que pour certaines personnes
c'est difficile ça a été le mauvaise
nouvelle et déjà c'est pas lui d'en
parler encore une fois je pense que ce
genre de sujet là voilà qui reste dans
les tuches effectivement c'est qu'il l'a
fait il n'est pas forcément tort sur le
fond mais il s'est loupé en terme de
j'adore la dernière fois il m'a mis une
cartouche là dans le ah bon ah ouais
dans Paris Match je sais pas quoi ah
quand il faisait l'émission
JE T'AIME tout ça tout ça je vais même
venir dans l'émission je te jure et
après il m'a remis une cartouche il
avait dit on ferait des personnes je
l'ai rappelé je l'ai rappelé je lui ai
dit bah écoute on va j'espère qu'on va
se croiser bientôt et j'ai jamais croisé
mais j'espère voilà parce que je pense
que je vais je vais j'espère qu'il aura
en tout cas il va avoir chaud quand il
va me prendre plein de baisser le
chauffage
non mais t'inquiète pas je frapperai pas
la violence
je suis le rencontrer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et je vous trouve injuste un comédien
plus sécurisé sur le l'actualité comme
une [ __ ]
c'est autre chose
c'est pas un modèle c'est pas un modèle
d'intelligence
dans ces trucs qui nous fasse pas chier
bon on va voir ce qu'on pensait que les
spectateurs tiens le tollé ah bah tiens
voilà abonnez-vous à 53%, merci les
téléspectateurs c'est pas exprimé le nom
je trouve que c'est pas mal
exprimera demain t'inquiète pas on sera
payé quand même nous emmerde pas